so how did you meet Justin Bieber funny
thing was Justin had like Loki crush on
my wife and at the time a lot of people
were Googling Asian Kim Kardashian I
remember me and my wife were going to
the Polo Lounge in Beverly Hills and I
ran into Kim Kim just finished having a
gym so she's like hey what's up blah
blah and then Kim was like oh this is
your girlfriend I was like yeah boom Kim
I told Rob her brother I was like man's
girlfriend looks [__] a lot like me
it was like a weird thing you know
so then I remember a studio engineer
told me it was like when you left Justin
Google Asian congratician to find out
your necklace and I was like oh that's
not a good thing right but yeah me and
Justin just connected I ended up making
grills for him for the first time and I
took Justin to career for the first time
like we've always been cool yeah been
friends with Justin for 12 years I think
so I'm like that